the search continues after Tuesday 7.1
earthquake in Mexico that killed at
least 295 people many were trapped in
collapsed buildings but the death toll
could have been higher without the
country's earthquake warning system it
speeds an alert to people miles away
from the quakes epicenter precious
seconds before the ground starts to
shake other nations have implemented
implemented similar systems but so far
the US has not at least not fully
despite our seismically active west
coast here to talk about it is Derrick
Thompson senior editor at the Atlantic
there at good morning good morning let's
talk about Mexico's state of the art
system first I've been around since the
90s right that's right yeah I mean it's
really interesting because you see that
you know Mexico has its own system Japan
has its own system China has its own
system there was maps they have taiwan
and turkey that have the systems as well
all of these countries developed their
early warning systems after catastrophes
so after the 85 Mexico earthquake killed
thousands of people
after the 95 Kobe earthquake in Japan
killed thousands of people after the
2008 China earthquake killed up to
90,000 people so it seems as if these
countries need a crisis a catastrophe
before they put together the system to
detect these earthquakes before they
reach people where they live how
accurate are the systems and how exactly
do they work right so imagine the
earthquake right occurring along a fault
line and in the shaking radiates outward
the waves are radiating outward from
this rupture at fault the once you put a
sensor right by that fault line and the
waves will trigger that sensor and then
send a message out to people miles and
miles away and now here's the key the
telecommunications move much much faster
than the earthquake so the text out runs
the shaking so you can get seconds of
warning but maybe even minutes if you're
never there further from right right
exactly from that fault and then when
you know you have minutes you don't just
have to duck and hide maybe you can even
leave the building and be safe outside
away from the edge of these buildings
because that's the most dangerous part
and do you get a set like does the alert
tell you how long you have also how much
time you have before it's gonna hit the
most advanced ones do so the most
advanced ones like the u.s. is
developing right now have systems where
they'll tell you where the epicenter is
what the magnitude is what the intensity
is that's actually the amount of shaking
but then they'll even show you a kind of
radar of the shaking approaching you so
as I was reading about this that what I
could only think of and this it might be
a little bit of a glib metaphor but you
know when you're on your phone looking
at the uber or lyft driver you could
actually have that information about
these shaking about the waves reaching
your zip code from the episode so I mean
there when something like a hundred and
forty million people in seismically
active areas of this country so how far
away are we from this and why actually
why don't we have a system right so the
answer to the latter question
unfortunately is three things it's price
is cost millions of dollars it cost
about 60 billions on buildings I know I
know but we're in a period right now
where people don't want necessarily to
act to prevent catastrophes until they
happen yeah and this is a story not just
of the US but it's also a story of the
world right these early warning systems
were built after the catastrophes happen
so one of the terrible things one of the
sadder things right now is that even as
you're seeing the benefits of these
early warning systems all over the world
the Trump budget nearly twelve twenty
seventeen actually zeroes out further
development of the West Coast early
warning systems
seems crazy you have to wait for that
for something tragic like that Derrick
thank you very much thank you it